colombia vive una nueva jornada de paro
nacional van 36 días y los que quedan
puesto que las negociaciones entre el
gobierno y el comité nacional de paro se
encuentran encalladas el ejecutivo de
iván duque está pidiendo que se levanten
los bloqueos que rigen en el país desde
el pasado 28 de abril mientras que el
comité nacional de paro está pidiendo al
gobierno que desmilitaricen ciudades
como cali además en estos momentos
iván duque también ha dicho que el
comité nacional de paro no representa a
los manifestantes y mucho menos a la
primera línea esto se enmarca cuando la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos ha confirmado que va a visitar
colombia entre el 8 y el 11 de junio
para comprobar las denuncias de
vulneración de derechos humanos que
están haciendo organismos sociales y
humanitarios aquí en colombia